on va perdre une interview alain decaux
raconte on se concentre en tant que
spécialiste vous allez nous répondre
louis xiv était il eût mieux que louis
xiii louis xiv et est divisible ce qui
n'est pas le cas de lille 13 c'est vrai
oui louis xiii était premier en fait
l'ancien régime et et inefficace non si
un régime c'était à base de plomb
pontpop ouais nous voyons les âges ou
habitant le plus de chance de croiser
des gens à la folie bonnes réponses
bonne réponse de mari n'a que sa
grossesse n'empêche pas d'avoir de
l'esprit pourquoi at on pris la bastille
le 14 juillet ben ça c'est évident en
leur sein n'a pas eu besoin de potasser
pour le savoir parce que comme si tu es
un jour férié le 14 juillet tout le
monde était libre pour pour les français
est ce que ça valait le coup de prendre
la bastille bah ouais en même temps pour
remettre l'opéra à la place c'était pas
terrible non c'est pas très malin
quelle est la particularité du château
de chambourcy crème de quoi était
inspiré d'une histoire vraie que c'est
l'instar du premier crime de l'humanité
mais pareil ça c'est toujours donc nous
on a une réputation de légèreté tout
mais pareil re en a fait une enquête on
a retrouvé le premier criminel de
l'humanité en a raconté son histoire de
ses biens ses sortants 2 et bien ouais
quand est apparue régime
régine la chanteuse à la renaissance
où est-il le plus facile de faire un
créneau
bon ça dans un château un château en
château fin j'ai noué donne on y voit là
j'ai compris ce désert mais qu'est ce
qui fait toute la journée avec voulu je
tapais ian brossât team sébastien ouvre
les yeux
je suis en train de me dire qu'il est
temps encore une fois de changer
l'équipe va mal de temps en temps faut
le faire il faut consommer c'est toi qui
as tu vas pouvoir dévier de morsures par
cindy dégage par exemple je dégage
existe-t-il d'autres types de château
laisse à taux faible c'est qu'ils les
sortent de deux châteaux de sable donc
par exemple qui avaient pas les moyens
ce n'est pas très costaud qu'elle n'est
pas la bouscule voilà c'est déjà trop
faible mais à la mi les gouvernements
sympa il est illégal à sofiane bekkouche
fait pas mal enfin franchement je pense
que vous avez manqué de respect à pascal
ouais mais je reste et je représente
c'est bien qui est le successeur de
napoléon c'est serge lama enfin bien un
que signifie la quarantaine pour elle
même et c'est bientôt fini
hall a alors 24 ans d'où vient le nom de
la 4l ben ça vient d'henri iv en fait
bien qu'ils avaient également pour les
pros les gens les plus riches avaient
créé le henry henry qui est devenu le 4
4 mais moi je veux
ça donne envie d'acheter quelques jeunes
filles 15 15 ah ben ça aussi ça c'est
l'égalité c'est mon beau tennis moi très
bien si vous sied aussi marignan mais
c'est marignane n'ya que c'est mal et
rendant les voix sur 2 bandes avant
c'est quand même
zéro